der prozess hätte vergangenen montag
hier schon starten sollen
nachdem es aber kurz prozessbeginn einen
technischen defekt im kühlraum des
kölner landgerichts gab wurde er um eine
woche verschoben
unter anderem waren damals die
klimaanlagen in den sälen nicht mehr
bereit und auch die untersuchungshaft
zelle in denen die angeklagten kurz vor
der verhandlung sitzen war total
verraucht deshalb startete mit west
jetzt heute morgen man muss es immer
wieder betone es ist wirklich
unglaubliches was diesen mann
vorgeworfen würden auch den anderen
wie genau verhält er sich jetzt vor
gericht zeigte reue
er kam in den gerichtssaal und man
erwartet natürlich bei diesen unfassbar
abscheulichen vorwürfe wirklich ein
monster das dann reinkommt und es war
ist erstaunlich normal würde ich sagen
also verdeckte zunächst dein gesicht
natürlich vor den fotografen mit einer
mappe auf dem das titelbild des films er
strafrichter abgebildet war
er setzte sich und er sprach auch nicht
viel als der richter ihn dann wagte wir
sind dann wenn sein vorname ist sagte er
sehr leise und fast schüchtern wirkt und
jörg er sprach nicht viel und auch
während der anderthalb stunden in denen
die staatsanwältin die widerlichen taten
die eltern haben soll vorlas starrte er
eigentlich durchgängig auf die andere
seite der wand und man konnte ihm kein
regen kein gefühl zu ordnen
das alles ist teil von missbrauchs
komplex bergisch gladbach kannst du für
uns noch einmal einordnen wie wichtig
dieser prozess jetzt also ist ja also
der prozess gegen jörg l ist insofern
wichtig als dass seine verhaftung im
herbst letzten jahres dazu führte dass
diese ermittlungen dieser berg an
material einfach aufgedeckt wurde
er hat ja die bilder oder soll die
bilder in chat über triemer geteilt
haben unter anderem und da hat die
polizei jetzt natürlich viele ansätze um
weitere täter festzustellen
aktuell wird gegen 83 beschuldigte
ermittelt den sind angeklagt bereits und
ja erst spielt quasi als schlüsselfigur
in diesem missbrauch